hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde da der erste teil so mega gut
ankam habe ich mir gedacht ich mache
einen zweiten teil von mir auf der
plattform optivo wir uns aber irgendwie
wir einstürzen machen wir standesgemäß
wieder unseren weihnachtlichen playmobil
kalender auf und zwar befindet sich ein
türchen nummer drei das hier
keine ahnung was das ist wie
meerschweinchen unerwartet wächst du
jemanden grüßen in meinem video ganz
liebe grüße linie
susanna sprachenlernen double o mein
gott ist krass ey hast dich dich hier
treffe es ist wahnsinn du kommst aus nrw
oder du kommst aus bayern oder nein wo
kommst du denn her
sachsen-anhalt baden-württemberg hamburg
niedersachsen mecklenburg vorpommern
schleswig holstein berlin bremen essen
aber wozu denn in deutschland wenn ich
ein video machen würde wen willst du
grüßen
meine freunde oder gar keine lass mich
raten du gehst in die siebte klasse
ja wo muss ich hallo was geht jetzt
hängt ihr das bild
das ist blöd mein gott was geht bei dir
ist ziemlich dunkel
ich dachte du wärst du sandra zukunft
weil dies genauso schwarz das ist er
super mit der ich sehe so sehe ich
möchte dir grüße
warum
nein wie geht es euch ja ich kann mir
auch luca nennen
zur familie alles gut gehe ich nehme
nicht auf hausaufgaben oder
weil ich wollte dich stört mich nicht
man was man hört mich nicht doch also
die anderen haben noch nicht gehört doch
man hört sich jetzt so dein fehler nicht
meine art
ja also meint rombach so dass ich mich
trifft mal zu ja ich sag den hong kong
kraft und nimmt den youtube video auf
die ganz unser kanal burschen bösen zu
china und russland auf einmal die schon
weiter und sorgen was 11.800 minutenlang
unseren podcast gehört
ja und nein uns jetzt schweigen 11.800
minuten das sind 196 stunden bist du
bekloppt hast du nicht versuchst du dir
hallo direkt maske abnehmen dass ich in
screenshot machen ja selbstverständlich
klar
hast du gard gefurzt aber dass der ton
vom screenshot fragen sich ob die
geschichte wahr ist was ich da sehe das
ist ein video was ich aufgenommen habe
seit ihrem klub gerade was ist verboten
eigentlich wenn corona stimmt stimmt
könnt ihr das ding drehen da im
hintergrund die stimmung ist ich dachte
gerade wir haben uns letztes mal schon
gesehen auf dem tv soll das so mit dem
herz da im hintergrund von der kugel du
bist partygirl mit einer discokugel im
zimmer als die beiden last nicht haben
ich wollte raten dann rate ich wo er
herkommt okay das hat vor dem mega gut
geklappt sagen hier kommt aus österreich
[Musik]
schleswig holstein
nein sachsen
nrw dann wieder wachsen ja dann sei sie
viel spaß in hof und der weihnachtsmann
man müsse diese teile nicht eigentlich
an den baum
[Musik]
in einem shooting mit pferden ich glaube
ich saß noch nie auf einem pferd nicht
mal richtig schiss vor
ich glaube ich habe ich noch nie gesehen
haben wie ihr vollidioten aus
könnt ihr mir die angst vor pferden
leben wir können wir helfen
das frage ich ja ich habe angst vor
pferden na ja und was machst du nein was
machst du gerade bist du dein handy im
jahr als ob ich jetzt getroffen habe
dich
mich ja wie ich bin ich gar nicht da 8
und jetzt ist er weg
drei wochen später so sage ich muss
gerade einkaufen gehen ach so ich habe
so ein supermarkt zwei meter neben mir
also ganz gekleckert
[Musik]
hallo macht ihr feuerwerk frankfurter
jungs
ach so
ist das nicht der rakete der lernt
was das denn
ich gehe gleich
die frankfurter jungs haben mich einfach
wegdrücken meine lieben freunde und
damit wichtige video an der stelle jetzt
auch beenden werden sie mit luca
gefallen hat dann lasse gerne einen
daumen hoch unserem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und schreibt mir
unten die kommentare wie viel angst ihr
auf einer skala von 1 bis 10 von den
frankfurter jungs hat
bei mir schon so
[Musik]